she writes
a small novel let called anthem a lot of
people have read that and it's it's
written in high schools
it's it's kind of dystopian novel uh and
uh
it's won't it doesn't get published in
the u.s it gets published in the uk uk
is very interested in dystopian novels
animal farm
uh and in 1984 84 was published
a couple years after i think after
anthem
there's reason to believe he read he
read anthem uh
that yeah and uh george orwell graduated
from animal farm yeah just the small
side animal farm is probably
top i mean i would it's weird to say but
i would say it's my favorite book
have you seen this movie out now called
mr jones no
oh you've got to see mr jones what's mr
jones
it's sorry sorry for my ignorance no no
it's a movie
it hasn't got any publicity which is
tragic because it's a really good movie
it's both
brilliantly made it's made by a polish
director but it's in english
it's a it's a true story and jojo wells
animal farm
is featured in it in the sense that
during the story
jojo was writing animal farm and and
he's
the narrator is reading off sections of
anna from as the movie is all
progressing
yeah and the movie is a true story about
the the first
western journalists to discover and to
write about the famine in ukraine
and so he goes to moscow and then he
gets on the train and he finds himself
in ukraine and it's
it's it's beautifully and horrifically
made so the horror
of the famine is brilliantly conveyed
and then and it's a true story said very
moving story very powerful story
and and just very well made movies so
it's it's tragic in my view that not
more people have seen it essentially i
was
actually recently just complaining that
there's not
enough content on the the famine the 30s
of
you know of stuff there's so much on
hitler like i love
yeah the reading i'm re reading it's so
long it's been taking me forever
the the rise and fall the third reich
yeah i love it
i've got the book to complement that
that you have to read it's called the
ominous parallels
it's leonard pikov and it's the ominous
parallels and it's about
it's about the causes of the rise of
of of hitler better philosophical causes
so whereas
the rise and fall is more of a kind of
uh
the the existential kind of what
happened um
but really delving into the intellectual
uh intellectual
uh comments that led to the rise of
hitler and
maybe highly recommend that and
basically
suggesting how it might rise another
that's the ominous parallel so the
parallel he draws is to the united
states and he says those same
intellectual forces are rising in the
united states and this is
this was published i think in published
in 81 82 it was published in 82. so it's
published a long time ago and yet
you look around us and it's unbelievably
predictive
sadly about the state of the world so i
haven't finished dying man's story i
don't want to i don't know if you want
me to no no
but on that point i'll have to let's
please return to it but let's
now for now let's talk let me also say
just just because
i i don't forget about mr jones it is to
the point you made there are tons of
movies
that are anti-fascist anti-nazi
and that's good but they're way too few
movies that are anti-communist
just almost none yeah and it's very
interesting and if you remind me late
i'll tell you a story about that
you